Ang tagumpay ng ating VQE algorithm ay lubos na
nakasalalay sa estado at circuit
na pipiliin nating simulan.
Ako si Victoria Lipinska at sa video na ito
tutuklasin natin ang mga opsyon
na mayroon tayo sa pagdidisenyo ng mga ito.
Tingnan nating mas mabuti
ang lahat ng elemento
na mayroon tayo sa bawat run ng quantum
na bahagi ng VQE.
Nagsisimula tayo sa reference state,
minsan tinatawag na initial state.
Pinapatakbo natin ang reference state
sa pamamagitan ng parameterized circuit na tinatawag na
variational form
na may paunang pagpili ng mga parameter,
at sinusukat natin ang estado
sa basis ng Hamiltonian
pagkatapos ng pagpapatakbo nito sa circuit
para makuha ang expectation value. Ngayon
dadaan tayo sa bawat isa sa mga elementong ito,
simula sa reference state.
Ang karaniwang pagpili para sa reference
state ay ang zero state.
Iyon ang estado kung saan ang isang quantum
computer ay nagsisimula na.
Para sa mga problema sa quantum chemistry,
maaari rin gamitin ang tinatawag na
Hartree-Fock State,
na siyang resulta ng Hartree-Fock
method.
Sa madaling salita, ang Hartree-Fock
theory ay nagbibigay ng simpleng paraan para itayo
ang reference state sa pamamagitan ng pag-approximate
ng ground state ng isang quantum system.
Naghahanap ito ng rotation
sa loob ng espasyo ng mga estado
na nagpapaliit ng ground state energy.
Sa wakas, ang reference state
ay maaari ring napaka-specific sa problema,
at maaaring gusto mong pumili
ng custom na estado.
Sa kaso na alam mo ang mga katangian ng
iyong sistema, halimbawa, mga simmetriya
o isang tiyak na bilang ng mga elektron
sa estado, maaari mong gamitin iyon
para magkaroon ng mas mabuting convergence ng VQE
algorithm.
Ang pagpili ng mabuting reference
state ay mahalaga para sa convergence
ang mga reference state na malapit sa
ground state
ay maaaring magpaconverge ng problema
nang mas madali at mas mabilis.
Kasinghalaga rin
ang pagpili ng mga paunang halaga ng parameter
na pinapasok natin sa variational form.
Samakatuwid, depende sa reference
state at mga paunang parameter,
maaari tayong mag-converge nang mabilis, dahan-dahan
o hindi mag-converge.
Tingnan natin ang plot na ito
at para sa mga layunin ng visualization,
isipin nating ang ating espasyo ng mga parameter
ay mayroon lamang isang parameter.
Ang napakamabuting reference state
ay maaaring magpahintulot sa iyo na magsimula nang napalapit
sa final ground state
at pagkatapos ay mabilis ang convergence.
Sa kabilang banda, kung nagsimula ka nang napakalayo
mula sa ground state dito,
reference state
a, kakailanganing tumawid ka sa mataas na enerhiya
na hadlang na magdudulot ng napakabagal na convergence
o walang convergence.
Tatalakayin natin ito nang mas malalim
sa classical optimization module
sa kursong ito.
Tingnan natin ngayon ang parameter circuit
na kumikilos sa reference state, a.k.a.
ang variational form.
Kapag ang circuit na ito, alam natin na ang U ng theta ay kumikilos sa reference
state,
nagbubunga ito ng tinatawag nating trial state
psi ng theta o minsan ansatz.
Ang ansatz state na ito ang
sinusukat sa angkop na basis
para makuha ang expectation
value para sa enerhiya.
Ang mga variational form
na tinatalakayin natin dito
ay inspirado ng chemistry.
Gayunpaman, tandaan mo
na mayroon din ang mga inspirado
ng quantum machine learning
at iba pang near-term
algorithm tulad ng quantum
approximate optimization algorithm.
Talakayin natin
ang ilang karaniwang pagpipilian para sa isang chemistry ansatz.
Ang Unitary Coupled Cluster o UCC
ay ang pamamaraang orihinal na iminungkahi
sa unang VQE na publikasyon,
at karaniwang ginagamit sa mga problema sa quantum
chemistry.
Karaniwang,
kapag nag-parameterize tayo ng quantum state,
nagtatrabaho tayo nang may exponentially
maraming parameter.
Gayunpaman, para gawing episyente ang mga preparation
circuit,
kailangan namin ng polynomial na bilang
ng mga operasyon
at samakatuwid ay polynomial na bilang
ng mga parameter.
Ang UCC ay isang halimbawa ng paraan ng paghahanda
ng trial state gamit ang ganitong circuit
at nagmumula ito sa coupled cluster
method,
na siyang gintong pamantayan sa quantum
chemistry.
Ang pinaka-karaniwang pagpipilian ay ang unitary
coupled cluster
singles at doubles
ansatz o UCCSD sa madaling salita.
Dahil ang UCCSD ay nakabatay sa tiyak na
electronic configuration ng isang problema,
kailangan nating tiyaking mayroon kaming reference
state na maayos na sumasalamin sa sistema.
Ito ang Hartree-Fock state.
Ang UCCSD ansatz ay karaniwang nagbibigay
ng magandang approximation ng ground state
dahil kumukuha ito ng single at double
na electron excitation sa isang ibinigay na molekula.
Ang bilang ng mga parameter sa UCCSD ay nag-i-scale
nang quadratically sa bilang ng mga spin
orbital.
Ang UCCSD ay maaaring mahusay na
ma-tailor sa isang problema,
ngunit sa kasamaang palad, ang quadratic scaling
ay humahantong pa rin sa napakalalim na circuit
na mahirap para sa kasalukuyang mga quantum
computer.
Kaya naman iminungkahi ng mga mananaliksik ng IBM
ang mas heuristic na diskarte,
kung saan maaaring i-tailor ang variational form
sa pinagbabatayan na hardware
na nagbubunga ng isang mahusay na
naisakatuparan na circuit.
Iyon ay, ang mga trial state ay parameterized
ng mga quantum gate
at ina-adapt
sa available na pisikal na device.
Ito ay napaka-heuristic na diskarte
na hardware friendly.
Batay sa mga halimbawang ito, tingnan natin
ang spectrum ng mga posibilidad
na mayroon tayo para ipahayag
ang aming variational form.
Marami sa mga ito
ay naipatupad na sa Qiskit
kaya hinihikayat kita na subukan nang ikaw mismo
kung alin ang pinaka-angkop
para sa problemang sinusubukan mong lutasin.
Kung titingnan natin ang graph, sa isang banda
mayroon tayong napaka-heuristic
na mga variational form.
Kapag mababa ang problem specificity ngunit
dinisenyo ang mga ito para ipatupad
sa tunay na hardware.
Sila ay napaka-expressive din, sa kahulugang
maaaring ipahayag ng isa
ang maraming quantum state gamit ang mga ito.
Gayunpaman,
ang isang problema na maaaring lumabas sa susunod na
yugto ng classical optimization
ay ang pagtagpo ng
tinatawag na barren plateau,
na tatalakayin natin sa susunod na module.
Sa kabilang banda,
mayroon tayong napaka-problem-specific na unitary
coupled cluster, na mahusay na gumagana
sa klasikal na chemistry ngunit
ay mahirap ipatupad sa quantum
hardware dahil sa malalim na circuit depth.
Sa pangkalahatan, mas magiging matagumpay ang mga kalkulasyon kung kaya mo,
una sa lahat, pumili ng reference state
at paunang set ng mga parameter
na lumilikha ng ansatz state
na malapit sa ground state.
At pangalawa, iwasan ang mga hindi kinakailangang parameter.
Ang mga ito ay nagdadala ng
mas malalim na circuit depth nang walang kabayaran
o lumilikha ng mas malaking parameter space
na hahanapin na humahantong sa mga plateau
sa classical optimization.
Kung aling mga parameter ang kinakailangan ay isang problema
na specific na tanong
na nangangailangan ng maingat na pag-iisip.
Pag-usapan natin kung nasaan ang ating guest of honor,
ang Hamiltonian, nanakatago sa lahat ng ito.
Gaya ng natutunan natin sa nakaraang seksyon,
ang Hamiltonian pagkatapos ng qubit
mapping ay kinakatawan bilang kabuuan ng
mga may timbang na string ng Pauli operator.
Sa huli, gayunpaman,
gusto nating suriin ang expectation
value ng ating Hamiltonian sa ansatz
state na ginawa ng variational form.
Sa kabutihang palad, ang quantum
mechanics ay maganda at linear
at ito ang gagamitin natin
para makuha ang expectation value.
Ganito ito gumagana.
Alam natin na ang Hamiltonian ay may timbang
na kabuuan ng mga Pauli
dahil sa linearity
ang expectation value ng kabuuan
ay katumbas ng kabuuan ng mga expectation
value ng bawat Pauli string.
Mabuti na, dahil gaya ng alam mo na, ang pagsukat sa Pauli basis
ay kasing simple ng rotation
ng standard measurement basis.
Sa halip na sukatin ang expectation value
sa napakalaking Hamiltonian na kinakatawan
bilang kabuuan, una tayong sinusuri ng expectation
values ng mga indibidwal na termino
at pagkatapos ay nagdaragdag sa huli
na may kaukulang mga timbang.
Ito ang dahilan kung bakit sa maraming resources
makikita mo ang single qubit rotation lamang
pagkatapos ng ansatz.
Ito ang nagpapatupad ng Hamiltonian
sa bawat pagpapatakbo ng circuit.
Sa susunod na video,
tutuklasin natin kung ano ang nangyayari
sa panahon ng hakbang ng classical optimization.
Kita tayo doon.